I'll put this gamer I'm going to tell
you some things about me and I wanted to
see if you think it's true okay but you
got to do that I can't say three things
Kay two truths and a lie babe yeah okay
okay
so when I was 17 years old I went to a
rehab called the McDonald Center let me
stop be real quick you're not gonna give
me like false information like one
little detail like where you were
wearing a red shirt but you're like no
it was a blue shirt no okay okay
no let's do that now no no she wants to
know though I just very important
question yeah so in nineteen when I was
in ninth when I was seven seventeen hmm
I went to the McDonald Sanchez rehab
technique okay did I or not you have to
say two truths three state oh yeah so
that statement one the second thing is
when I went to Paris I also went to
right after that I also went to Tokyo
England and Japan no Tokyo Japan I went
to Tokyo Japan even okay England and
Australia in that order
no so right after Paris yeah in this
prick I went to all those places at that
during that dress Tokyo England what
else Australia England France France in
a span of how long a month okay okay and
the third one is I last night I hung out
with Jeremy Piven I don't know your life
though I know but just is it nasty
stutters yes she knows this one I want
it I want to see if you know I'm not
gonna recapture to true so the first one
was on
I went to a rehab called the McDonald
Center uh-huh when I was 17 okay I win
this trip I went to Japan Japan Japan
London Australia
hundun in Australia that's not what
Jeremy Piven Jeremy Piven is what a lie
[Applause]
because you try too hard yeah got it on
the first two to make it seem like a lie
yeah that you weren't unsure I think it
was a double line man you want to do
what with her no no II won't be able to
read it all right all right
you do it what is it yeah yeah think
about no you have to just do it on the
spot like I did okay two truths and a
lie
yeah order alright that's the whole
point in a line yeah any order with the
lie is ready yeah yeah bit ready okay
okay geo Internet your turn
oh [ __ ] alright so when I was 19 I was
pulling out of my driveway uh-huh
and I accidentally ran over my dog okay
and he died so he died yeah okay uh and
then I think of another one this is this
is hard
yeah your games yeah um I didn't have
sex until I was 19 okay and one I saw my
parents having sex the dog didn't die
[ __ ] sounds good how do you know I'll
tell you why I here I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why okay so relax Lu why
because you saw that I had two dogs here
right yeah
and you were really like friendly about
it and I feel like you would have said
that what I Phi if I'm in a house as he
to dogs oh my god I love dogs
oh man when I was 19 you know you know
that wasn't the most information yeah
and the two other statements were like
declarations almost yeah yeah I was
trying to convince myself to do to be
the guy oh we've done this all right all
right
I'm awful at it you are at giving two
truths and a lie I'm good at guessing
not the other way around
oh I see I can't offer up information
yeah when I'm trying to like come up
with some that should be a game we play
every week it's fun yeah yeah it's a fun
game it's tough my heart was like my
throat yeah you're intimidating
I am yeah I looked at you know blink
yeah no don't blame yeah yeah why can't
blink I think I think I would because
the thing is is that I think I can get I
can pretend truths or lies oh that's how
to pass it yes so what I would do is
this I would if someone would ask me
like have you ever had cabbage mmm you
know I would pretend that I haven't to
make my body react Yeah right and that
did you murder you know Bryce no you
mean you established a baseline so the
cabbage and the burner would be at the
same you know same wavelength wavelength
right well this is how I'm gonna try it
right and they're like okay he didn't
kill Brian but I did we should should
buy one yeah someone pretty bad kiss my
where it gets really know what they
should have a lie detector just built in
my body yeah right and he has like a
little green light in a red light and
then here it's unsure that a yellow
neutral yeah I saw the movie the color
purple it turns red
no I didn't throw your coat to it just
like a red light
yeah why are your nuts excellent because
what would be one color no we got to be
able to see it yeah
what do we have time we're over an hour
okay oh wow that's quick pretty good
yeah this is nuts
what do you mean I want to keep going no
we're not done oh I feel like you're
trying to kick me out the whole time you
really
I brought the [ __ ] photo from the
[ __ ] enemy right yeah Waterloo yeah I
remember Louvre at this trip you know
this trip um I didn't appreciate it I
didn't I can't believe you did I be M
campaign right that's why you went to
Australia and Japan yeah I was paid to
go and then the whole crew was like
we're gonna go to the Louvre I'm like I
don't know what it is and I went and I
wasn't Mona Lisa and you were
disappointed not cute I was oh yeah
you're pretty cute how old were you
there 28 you look like a raver young
yeah junko jeans yeah and like a puka
shell necklace yeah it looks like you
are wearing a puka sure are you wearing
a puka shell [ __ ] no I'm not I don't
know what that is
[Music]